but first the newspaper today makes some
uncomfortable reading for the Labour
Party leadership reports of rifts
between jeremy corbyn's most senior
advisors and his closest allies and
around bring with the BBC after half a
dozen of former party staff broke
gagging clauses to speak out about the
way the party handles complaints the
party's shadow international trade
secretary Barry Gardner joins us now
thank you very much for being with us in
the studio this morning and I just want
to start with the story that is on the
front page of The Sunday Times reports
that around half a dozen former Labour
Party staffers are going to go against
gagging orders to talk to panorama about
their concerns over the way complaints
are handled in the Labor Party and the
Labour Party is allegedly going to see
them I mean I thought you the party that
were on the side of workers we
absolutely do not use gagging orders to
hide anything that is illegal or
improper we use gagging orders only to
stop them former members of staff from
leaking confidential information where
we have an obligation to protect
individuals and from doing that in a
party political or partisan way for
political purposes so let me be clear
about that because actually we have
suggested that there should be
legislation we have actually as a party
said that we would bring in legislation
where we see companies using gagging
orders NDA's non-disclosure agreements
and to cover up anything that is you
know like racism or sexual abuse or
illegal illegal practices it wouldn't
wouldn't concerns over anti-semitism
fall under that very legislation then
because no discrimination yeah look I I
welcome any objective impartial
investigation that is going to help us
to get rid of anti-semitism in the
labour party let me make that absolutely
clear my understanding of this program
is that it has not been balanced and
impartial in that way and indeed what
has happened is that the people who are
involved
in in the NDA's and breaking those
non-disclosure agreements have said have
used selectively correspondence from
about 18 months ago when we were in
between general secretaries and what
they've done is that they have taken
information where they said please help
us in these cases please give us advice
give us guidance they haven't used that
they haven't said that and where that
guidance has come they have and said we
believe there should be a stronger
response than you have recommended they
haven't used those in the program so
it's difficult to comment on a program
which I haven't seen but my
understanding is that it is not a
balanced and objective investigation
into anti-semitism it is a very partial
view from a few members of staff who
have a political axe to grind is it the
problem here though the fact that who
gets to decide whether or not
whistleblowing is done in the right way
surely it shouldn't be the people who
are being whistle blown against I mean
if this was another company labor would
speak out against it no no sorry I said
very clearly distinguish between the
what is a perfectly proper
non-disclosure agreement you will have
an NDA with with Sky News I'm quite sure
that you are not able to say certain
things if you leave if you leave the
company which are confidential to the
nature of the business that is the NDA's
that we believe has been breached
that's perfectly proper what is not
proper is to have an NDA in which would
cover up anything that's illegal or
immoral and and that we have never done
and we would oppose it so but look I
think it's let's see the programme but
my my understanding is that it has not
been the sort of impartial objective
view that I certainly would welcome to
help us get rid of the anti-semitism
that sadly does exist in a very very
small minority of cases in the labour
party the Sunday Times also reports that
Dinah Bert and John McDonnell have urged
Jeremy Corbyn to sack two of his closest
aides because they
in quotes keeping him captive ya know
the the the idea that they put forward
that there is civil war in the Labor
Party let's look at the real divide in
this country the real divide in this
country is not within the Labor Party
the real divide in this country is
between what the Conservatives are
trying to do with our country and the
rest and no Buffy really at a time when
there is a social care crisis destroying
the lives of our elderly people when
there is a knife kind crisis that is
destroying the lives of our young people
we have no no ninja in Jeremy Hunt last
week he was talking about bringing back
fox hunting right Boris Johnson was
talking about the 700 thousand pound pay
cut he might have to take in order to
sacrifice himself to become our prime
minister these guys are completely out
of touch with what is going on in this
country and what they should have been
talking about is why they're both of
them breaking their promise made at the
last general election that they would
protect the TV licenses free TV licenses
for the over 75 so if you want to look
at the real divide in this country the
real issues that's what they are and we
are being presented with Tottori content
in that 160,000 in Tory Party members
are going to decide the future of our
prime minister they will have a vote we
don't have code they will have a vote
and when they have a vote some of them
about it - okay
they will then decide the future of this
country I'm sick of it I want to
generally lecture to deal with you
nation if you want a general election
then can you commit that labor will call
a no-confidence vote and whoever becomes
prime minister before and you spra can't
for the summaries will we'll call a
no-confidence vote when we believe that
those conservative members of parliament
who have said that they would support a
no-confidence motion in the government
in order to stop the No Deal are likely
to support are you having those
conversations with of course of course
because the key thing here is and look
at what a No Deal would in
so it that means that means I just want
to pick that means it's likely to be but
from what you're saying it sounds like
it's more like to be in the autumn well
I don't know because I can't read the
minds of those conservative MPs who've
said that they're prepared to do this
but what we do know is that every
business organization in this country is
telling us that a No Deal brexit would
be a disaster for jobs and our economy
and yet we have these two leadership
contenders in the Conservative Party who
say no no we really mean it we're very
happy to take us out on to a No Deal
this is a disaster for our country and
and we seem to be sleepwalking into it
and all these other things our periphery
we have to focus on what is happening to
our company well let's do that let's
focus on the things that happen to this
country and brexit if there is an
election as you want will of course need
to know crystal clear what Labour's
policy is so does labour want to stay in
the EU or do you want to leave the EU
look our policy has moved right we
started off arms with yeah of course
because I asked asked this question so
much and it does feel sometimes that you
just get these lengthy supplies that
just don't really onto what it's a
really straight question okay you you
you straight the question too banal
straight yeah okay great
does labour want to stay in the EU or
lita EU labour has always been an
internationalist party we wanted to stay
in the EU and reform it what then
happened was we had a referendum where
the people said they wanted to leave and
we have tried to respect that we've
tried to hold in tension our view that
actually economically in terms of jobs
in terms of the economy we would be
better off staying in the EU with the
democratic accountability to the people
and that is why we try to negotiate the
deal with the government to make sure
that we could honor the referendum
result but they would not move they
refused to change their red lines they
refused to look at a customs union in
which we would have a say they
absolutely blocked that and that is why
we have had now - to move to the end of
the
process that we we outlined at our party
conference and to say in that case we
will do anything to stop a no deal
brexit because you look at the trade
statistics that came out last week the
investment in this country new projects
down by 14% new jobs from that
investment down 24% and the investment
that is protecting existing jobs down
54% this is what is happening as a
result of brexit chaos in every country
that the Tories have led us to if there
is an election then as a result of a
no-confidence vote which really could
happen by the end of the year we'll
leave a campaign to stay in the EU or to
leave we did before the the first
referendum and obviously we decide in a
democratic way our party's policies
arrive then it's a closed five meeting
which which means that all the the key
elements of our party come together they
decide what our manifesto commitments
are that's what we did last time that's
what design include members oh yes of
course
then in non-members don't end up taking
taking this is important isn't it
because it does feel like different
parts of the labor movement want
different things
no the labor movement wants a Labour
government they want to get rid of this
Conservative government that is causing
such distress in our society that is a
roading of ambach services do you want
what and yes we have always been a
remain and Reform Party okay we tried to
reconcile ourselves with what the
Democratic will of the people was at
that referendum and we try to do that
sincerely but we always said we would
not accept a No Deal we now have two
conservative putative prime ministers
who are saying they are happy to take us
out on a new deal and people in the
Conservative Party conservative MPs are
saying that they would side with a
Labour motion of no-confidence in their
own government because they see the
disaster that is waiting for the British
public if those two get the chance to
get into Danny's okay Barry Gordon thank
you very much for coming on
program this morning